it's like I've always said a woman can
make a guy a better person or drive him
batshit insane crazy stupid love now
this movie lives up to its title because
it's about all the dynamics of love some
crazy some stupid all love and there are
few storylines in this movie but the
main one Steve Carell his wife Julianne
Moore tells them hey I cheated on you
and I want a divorce
and then Steve Carell does what a lot of
guys do and that is slump into
depression and go hang out in a bar not
a shitty seedy bar so you know a nice
bar where he meets Ryan Gosling who
absolutely does not have the problem of
relationships but I liked about Ryan
Gosling in this movies he is what every
guy thinks he is when he goes to a club
or a bar I mean he dresses nice he's
suave he knows how to talk to women he
knows everything to say ladies when you
see a guy in the club yes he's actually
thinking oh I'm Ryan Gosling up in here
so Ryan Gosling kind of takes Steve
Carell under his wing and he's like you
know what dude I'm gonna take you under
my wing I'm gonna teach you how to talk
to women you are gonna be a ladies man
and so he does and he does it's awesome
I'll say Ryan Gosling had the lines in
the movie there is one line that he says
about the battle of the sexes I actually
died laughing that's when I was like
this movie just moved up and that's just
one of the many storylines in this movie
and everyone was really good in this
movie Steve Carell was good Ryan Gosling
was good Emma Stone was good all the
side characters they were good I think
what I liked about it is as much as I
like friends with benefits it still did
what a lot of romantic comedies do
nowadays and that is revolve the movie
around sex as funny as that can be there
are other things to talk about yeah Ryan
Gosling's character got a lot of ass but
that never built a relationship for him
so it's different like I said before
this movie deals with all aspects of
love so whether you've just had a crush
before you've been in full-blown love I
don't see why you wouldn't be able to
relate to this movie
if you don't relate to this movie in
some way shape or form cancel your
Warcraft subscription and go meet
somebody worst case scenario you get
your heart crushed to a pulp and two
things happen you relate to Crazy Stupid
Love and you realize I'm right about
relationships when me twin I mean I'll
be honest I heard this movie was so
great so I went into this movie going
all right it's gonna be way too artsy
for me I'm not gonna relate it's gonna
be a mess for me anyway and I walk out
of there going no that's just a well
made movie it's like this movie was made
by a person or people who were hopeless
romantics with the right amount of
damage just enough to make a movie
really good and relatable to everybody
it was like a realistic movie that was
feel good enough
but not cheesy so I will say I would buy
this movie even on blu-ray it would be a
weird addition to my blu-ray collection
next to you know Lord of the Rings and
Iron Man and this movie but it deserves
that rating it's really good here it is
I put a link to a song in the
description below listen to that song if
you like that song you'll probably like
Crazy Stupid Love in one way shape or
form here's a club story from me this
really happened I was at this bar slash
Club place this one girl looks at me she
was really attractive too and she was
like hey I think you should buy me a
drink first thing she said to me and
then I looked at her and I was like do I
know you and she was like well no then I
went then why would I buy you a drink
not that I'm opposed to buying a girl a
drink or anything like that but when she
asks for it she expects it like that now
she's just pissing me off so I thought
it was hilarious she was a little more
than pissed about it guys if you're
hoping to close don't do that shut up
I'm still Ryan Gosling and if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more